[Music]
don't you dare news don't you first have
you ever seen that Isaac don't you dare
Mexican boy I feel like I might have
when he was a toddler mm-hmm I like it
when kids pick up growing up like
Peniston cute I have my nephew when he
was like three he would win something in
accident or something he would go oh my
oh my submitted by Ana banana Oh a guy
who wanted to ask his girlfriend to lose
weight gets destroyed online now let me
ask you this guy was it for health
purposes because you were worried about
he just wants fucky-fucky time or is it
like a lot of lines of you know back in
the day you both were fit then you guys
let yourselves go and the attractions
gone and you kind of missed that I think
both are pretty solid yeah what's wrong
oh that pretty valid or was it like hey
you're fat I don't like you anymore
cuz that's the bad part that sounds
valid - all right well let's continue
that story it's valid but it's a [ __ ]
up way to go about it
kasumi has the same thing I was like hey
you're lazy get a job it's just whatever
state you're in it's [ __ ] up change
that [ __ ] cuz like Mariel consistently
tells me that I'm really fat
she still kisses me so it's all good
girls are more forgiving oh they are
though they are very forgiving they see
through all that blubber mm-hmm it's
nice I'm going through the bulk in the
shred the bulk of the shadow the bulk
and the shred yeah sometimes I look at
meri I'm like your standards are really
low you need to really really think
about what you're doing with your life
what you don't think that you're a great
catch David I'm a great catch but
physically I'd quite love myself
sometimes I wake up in the morning I'm
like you look fantastic - your since you
even brush your teeth today I did I'm
very clean come on now okay you've never
smelled like David is clean
I even tried a new detergent smell it
let's go screw then I thought you said
deodorant so I went down I like how you
went directly for the paper smell that
smells great too but this detergent is
fantastic this is it I don't I got good
Vanessa recommend it was fantastic I
need to get it all right that's good
mommy the smell your old telling
everyone on the internet almost smell
you afterwards we should get that too
okay I'm down as smelly I can't count
that got the best lawn that's why I love
wrestling messages what about that
psychos variation the way bar was
walking over to David's death is like
this was like walking sideways 10 men
these are like ass big feet where you
can't move okay so anyways this story it
was posted on humans of New York so it's
a baby at first I told myself I could
get past it I said let's just see how it
goes we had excellent dates everything
else about her was exactly what I wanted
I didn't want to ruin something good for
that one little reason but it's been 1.5
years and I feel horrible but I just
can't get past it and I feel like a bad
person for being bothered by it I can't
bring myself to tell her we're going to
couples therapy next week but I still
don't think I'll be able to say it is
there any right way to ask someone to
lose weight for you yeah that's the post
okay how fat is she
show us I don't have a pony his whole
like an ottoman almost yeah so then
commenters I mean that's best stuff
here's the thing you are entitled to
your purposes and if you aren't
attracted to overweight women there's
nothing wrong with that the problem is
that you've now led her on for a year
and a half and wasted her time
truth trying to get past it and since
you can't you want her to change for you
you should have never started dating her
if you knew there was an issue for you
from the
getting yeah but what is he supposed to
do now that's like lecturing him about
the past well yeah I mean that's a lot
of people are just pointing that out and
then that's how you should have got your
act together in high school but you
wouldn't be in the state you are right
now he goes yeah but right now I need
money so what should i do should I get a
job but no one junior high you because
they're not offering solutions at
reprimanding yes yeah it's like it's
something he can't take that information
and better his life because he wasn't
asking is it [ __ ] up or not he was
asking like what can I do yeah
nope sorry if they're not attracted to
her then you're not attracted being nice
by dating someone you're not a hundred
percent into will never work been there
done that it only leads to massive
resentment we all have preferences she
deserves someone who wants all of her
and you deserve someone you're into
without having to change yeah yeah I
thought it was gonna be like she let
herself go no but he's been it's like
you knew when you were getting yourself
in another life you were praying that's
like if I if I dated against the girl
and I'm upset that she's a criminal
she's been smuggling people and shooting
guns and robbing liquor stores the
easiest way to can lose is to drop your
sorry deadweight ass I don't think
that's not your mean what is that a dude
with that dude hey what about what about
an opposite thing so for example like
let's say let's say like you guys
started having a new taste effect - for
the big ones you know so when you got
with like a big dick no like a like a
fat dude oh my god yeah or like a fat
woman right so like you know not super
fat but there are really good-looking
chubby or people out there yeah it
tastes do change yeah like like Casey he
had a little weight but you got skinny
before you met you know and then what if
you saw his old pictures in your life
damn you kind of cute you know and then
and then what what about the author is
it [ __ ] up to ask the opposite hey to
gain some weight can you get a little
fatter I think so yeah what the hell
thing right I know for me it's more like
um it kind of sucks cuz it's like asking
something I'm that of them that they
don't they might not even want you know
like they're happy with how they are
you've been telling them that you're
happy with you know what you have
and then it's just saying like what can
you can you do this like I think
bringing it up once just to have that
conversation I think that's fine but
then anything past that once they're
like no I kind of like the way I feel I
kind of like call them and they're not
unhealthy and I'm like that's [ __ ] up
yeah but I think like it should be okay
to have a conversation a conversation
fine yeah I think I think bringing it up
in conversation is fine but then
anything past that once they say like no
I'm cool like this there's no there's no
health issues there's nothing there's no
there's no discussion ah yeah yeah boys
like I haven't even had my discussion
yet there was one comment I don't have
it here but they were saying like well
either way if you bring it up and if
it's not something she wants to do or
that she like it's not something that
she wants to change about herself then
you're screwed both ways like she's
always gonna have that in the back room
is always gonna be like like I'm not
good enough exactly she's always gonna
be she's not good enough for him yeah
it's like you no matter which way you go
if it's not something she wants you're
[ __ ]
so what do you do as a guy just this is
what you do you lazy son of a [ __ ] so
you get into Fitness yourself you become
motivated invite her to come join you in
fun physical activities hopefully she
gains a passion for one of these
activities and before you know it you're
both growing together as people and
being fit no conversation needed because
it's not about looking a certain way but
it's just about living healthy together
so Sean McNulty said if you're concerned
about her health approach it from that
angle if you're concerned about her
appearance you should probably just stay
single because the thing is if he's
telling her you need to diet you need to
[ __ ] do that do whatever he's not
getting fit he's not eating right he's
just genetic like he's just normal like
you know average weight whatever that's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I think like be I
think like the outrage is it's like
societal base to you know what I mean
and there's also this knit concept of
this like I don't think people
understand this as well there's like a
like having them get it you know I mean
like people are allowed to have their
preferences there's nothing wrong with
that so some people say like well you
should love her for a personality well
maybe that's not the way that guy loves
it's okay for that person because he
could just find somebody else that
matches him and I think it's kind of
wrong sometimes when people get angry at
somebody else for not having their sin
same definition of what attractiveness
or same values today
exactly if his values is I'm I only like
physical [ __ ] which is obviously he
isn't if that's his [ __ ] values and
he's allowed to have that and find
somebody who hast has that too
the only issue is is that he let her on
for a year and he was unrealistic with
his expectations and maybe she fell in
love with him now or you can just give
him the benefit of the doubt he didn't
know what he wanted he was really
attracted to her personality but we all
know that once the honeymoon phase so
that's where he kind of [ __ ] that that
tells me he has low self-esteem because
he was going for something that was kind
of cool it always bothered him anything
not necessarily not necessarily because
I can't get with someone we're in the
back of my mind it's lingering that
there's something that I'm not happy
with all those things happen after the
fact Adam the blankness is gone and I'm
like oh I see faults I'll show this and
then you guys tell me if it was maybe me
being a younger age and maybe more in
maturity but I did date a guy that I
didn't find very attractive like
physically he just wasn't my type in
every regard I was in high school yeah
physically it just was not attracted to
him but he had a really dope personality
and I really like that you know and then
once that whole honeymoon phase or
whatever just kind of like died off then
it was just now I'm stuck with like bad
habits that he might have that might get
on my nerves and then couple that with
I'm already not like super physically
attracted to him like then at that point
I'm like oh [ __ ] like I felt like a like
in too deep you know at that point but I
don't know if it was because I was young
and I was just like more naive or you
know that also to like this issue of
people are like outraged by it I think
like this is stuff that a lot of people
go through though cuz you know once
again for him maybe this is a learning
experience for him is that you actually
do care more about parents's than you do
personality you know and that's
something that he's learning here is
that about himself that doesn't mean
you're a [ __ ] dick is shallow
chef is it that's his preference cuz
it's not like it would be a different
story if this guy put up this comment
and said like yo she's a [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] I can't be it you know it's not
even that case he's asking for help
right now where he's like I feel like
there's something wrong with me that's
the part I feel bad about cuz he's like
being vulnerable baby because in a very
honest way where it is hard on the
sleeve and people just straight roasting
his ass he's almost like hey guys I need
some help for tea
think about this like this next comment
and it says so much hate here he's
grappling with the fact that he's not
physically attracted to someone he
deeply cares about he's not some raging
misogynistic thank you misogynistic
douchebag he's a real person telling
someone something he feels very
conflicted about now now isn't the time
to insult him instead it's time to gain
insight on how other people think and
feel in other words empathy I'm saying
that's why I'm telling you they're fat
and angry because they're projecting
hello guys I hope you guys enjoy the
video please remember to give us a big
thumbs up and a like like like and also
when you guys sign on YouTube make sure
just kidding news are the first thing
you watch every single day because we
post videos every day ok for more videos
[Music]
[Applause]